the U.S government intentionally
poisoned Americans during prohibition
Bootleggers hired chemists to make
industrial alcohol drinkable when the
government realized what was happening
they added toxic substances that
Bootleggers couldn't extract a startling
number of drinkers began to drop dead
adding poison didn't stop folks from
drinking and the FEDS didn't care
leading the New York City medical
examiner to charge the government with
the moral responsibility for the deaths
by the end of prohibition the federal
poisoning program is estimated to have
killed more than 10 000 people yes this
really happened